extensions I'm going to talk about this
morning that's going to be in fact our
heading briefly I've given you all and
GV you should grandmother's between grab
a seat I've given you all the reference
sheet and I'm highlighting because even
though you're nurturing expansions when
you first learn to read expansions last
year this didn't exist ok so the vast
majority of you will probably not refer
to this very much um but in fact if you
have a look at the extension one side
trick extensions these anxieties that
the first thing that appears so what are
really quickly since you need to are
some of you will good money some of you
will actually use this affair over time
I want all of you to be familiar with
how this thing works so if you what then
here you can make is a edgerson
identities
and one of the thing that I want to
point out to you is if you have a look
you've seen this before what back when
it was first published but if you just
quickly skip over both sides one of the
things that you will notice is that it
was interesting when they were designing
it what are things you'll notice is that
number one there is no explanation as to
what any of these formulas is it's like
what is just talking about what are the
terms in on that extension one side that
you're looking at you can see there's
this son on the right hand side it's a
simple harmonic motion and then there's
this weird thing which has x + 2 dots of
it which is like some reader emoticon
which is an emoticon and then n squared
and x adobe you have no idea what any of
those are and then don't go to F any
effort to explain it this is the exact
opposite of the way mathematics general
to has what they call the formula and
data sheet and it's got like sentences
all over explaining what the actual for
news are and how to use them okay as
calculus students you're expected to be
able to understand these folders well
and this is really just a fallback its
kind in wards a memory aid that's all it
is so also you'll notice if you turn to
save our mathematics sign which is the a
5 a-5 side you have a look at say I have
a look at the question rule it's in the
third column 1 2 3 3rd calm it's about
half or a third the way down and you
should recognize it because the owner or
which has a question in it if y equals
you on V you see it there now they're
giving you the question all the
right-hand side but you'll notice it's
not the form that we're used to sing it
in right why don't we usually write it
in this form
because this [ __ ] are cooking we use the
dashes because it's faster it's easier
to remember however I've laid at the
point that the dashes like they're not
the best way of doing the notation like
do we really do we really know whether
that is a dash or one well i could if i
wrote one I'll write it exactly the same
way like who's really going to write it
like that you should really thinking
about it but but no one really so this
is actually a much better way of writing
it just happens to take forever and one
of the things you need to get used to if
you're going to refer to this sheet is
you need to get used to the way that
they're using it so you don't get
confused by using this sheet that's the
last you want in exam to be like in a
burner that you look at this sort of
like oh yeah let me just double check
and yeah oh I'm even more confused
itself it's not a good position to you
so that's kind of one of the things i
want to highlight without angle some
ideas let's write down the first one
let's just write it down you will notice
that we usually write it in a Sabine's
that's because each of these are easy to
write it easy to say but they have
written them in features and what's that
other angle it's a my good old fire ok
so then provided for us three of the
identities just the sum ok so this is
sign off just two angles and then just
made component notebook and they've got
the identity right there ok so we can
quit it sign
and you can see that they switch over
from so close to co-sign because they're
keeping in order of angles right just
like we would if we do a B we'd go a
plus B may be a thief which means you've
got to switch this uncovering now this
is the sum identity for sine right
you'll notice they have it included the
difference identity and the reason why
is because the difference identity this
time I hope you're a call from what we
prove it it flows directly out of the
sub identity do you remember a
difference is just simply adding a
negative right it's just adding a name
now if I know that it's adding a
negative I can fit it straight back into
this and instead of five here here I'm
going to have negative five right
now why is this useful to me why is it
handy to be able to say that what kind
of what knowledge can I take advantage
of this point yes sign is another
function then having a negative on nice
like negative f of X inside means they
can be negative
good right and just corresponding to
that not only assign and odd function
cosine is an even function right so
cause of negative I is the same as cause
of fun ok so I'm going to go and I'm
just going to buy that like you and if
you want to make a tag for yourself you
know just on top of where you've got the
negative fired I would write this guy is
even that's why I decided to peers and
this is odd which is why I can trick the
Saudis ok simple right the clothes and
Tanner that these are exactly the same
way and you'll find this over and over
again throughout the sheet you'll find
results but you're like the results
missing they're not missing it's just
there the results that aren't included
are easily gotten from the roles that
are already there ok oh this is in fact
one of the design principles that you
can go on the water slide you can see
their release the one-page document they
talk about like why did they include
what are they what they put and why did
they reveal what they are made of stuff
like this for this exact reason ok then
try to see do you understand the way
auditing functions work you should be
able to get to here quickly to them
let's just rehearse them in cars
so so all of these results right this
should function as a memory aid to you
right it does not really change what can
be quoted and one cut so for example let
me pick what out go to the mathematics
site and under and they don't even call
it the heading I'm going to coordinate
geometry section which is the second
column right at the top you've got
distance perpendicular distance gradient
and the quick grading form of the
equation of a line and you can see I
prep as you're looking through that list
there are a lot of things missing from
there that you know you can quote for
example distance gradient there's a
third thing you always learn at the same
time remember quite a geometry see
things that you can do with two points
so okay you're going a little bit
further i would say midpoint right
distance gradient midpoint they're all
there the three things you can work out
if you've got two points okay you wonder
how far they are what the slope is and
where the middle is ok now midpoint is
not there but midpoint is definitely
credible right in the same way right
yeah you've got that's that's a division
of an interval time yeah exactly so if
you turn over to be extension one side
which is a bit sticky admittedly for
your change if you see you've got the
division of an interval in a given ratio
what's a midpoint what ratio is there
it's one to one and sure enough if you
put m equals 1 and N equals 1 you get
the familiar big boy from okay so-so no
we let this muscle in exactly the same
way if you have a look back at the quick
radiant form right you see they haven't
provided to report there have been right
but that's because 2.4 is like one line
away from point gradient form I all you
do is just rearrange slightly cxu
fractions so in terms of like what could
I quite what can I not quote if it's not
on there that doesn't mean because
quarters right
still just as just as usable okay but
all they're saying is look we shouldn't
need to provide this to you to aid your
memory of this thing could easily be
like 10 pages long if they included
every single formula you ever
encountered but it's a bit excessive in
the same way that for instance I don't
think where is it I just looked at oh
yeah okay look under the derivatives on
the mathematics side you can see there's
the solution of a quadratic equation
right there's the quadratic formula yeah
there's not discriminate there that it
tell you what what Delta is but that's
because they don't need to do that if
you understand what the quadratic
formula does it make sense do you see
how the principles work together to
create this they made and then see a
point in st. descriptive equals b
squared minus 4ac you should understand
that how come they haven't included the
double angle voyage why have they
included sine 2 theta okay because what
I'm going to do is I'm going to go
straight from here another say well what
if five feet are the same angle right so
I'll go sign of theta plus feet up and
I'm going to go ahead sine theta cos
theta cos theta sine theta and that
gives me my result immediately okay so
the difference identity and the double
angle identity are just specific
instances of this song identity now
there's a great questions Thank You
faster those let's just we're in the
middle of doing the cosine one right now
wonder your rib is it without going to
the sheet it's a yes cos cos minus side
side right so it cos cos minus sign sign
and this is one is wonderful places
where like in real life if an engineer
or an actuary or something what's to use
a formula and they want to make sure
they nail it they look something off
okay so if you're if you're ever unsure
you're like I know one of them flips
assignment which one isn't one here it
is right you don't never ever need to
dash and I'm going to skip all the steps
to think you can see the way it works if
I
now take the difference okay what
difference will this make this this
pilot have a look here adds up ads are
no difference here right because it's
causing cause and certain function what
difference will it make here and it will
mean that this introduces not negative
so that's why we're going to get cause
cars plus sign so now I'm not even going
to go to the effort of writing the 10
one because I think again leave now I
will point out that the tan one there is
the sum go very quickly to the
difference and that's what takes you
straight to angle between two lanes
right because you're taking ten are at a
difference of angles okay and so that's
where when you have a look at the sheet
right you have a look at side right
there you have a look at that tan theta
plus tan Phi or 1-10 in a tan Phi okay
that's your turn off the two different
angles or just want the difference and
so you're going to get like each of
those is an m1 and an m2 recognizes from
N equals 10 Peter way back from a we
first learn I'll write it will find the
true okay so you can see how you can use
it as a memory now what you need really
is some time to work with these and like
I said recalibrate your brain into
Radian mode so the first thing you want
to do is get to exercise 14.8 40d arms
which you did actually do part of last
year but I said to you now there are
some pies and we things talking to you
about radians in Versailles
just ignore them now is the time should
not ignore them okay so go to 14 big do
and for this I would take about half or
maybe less than please do all the
questions in radians in addition to that
what I'm amount up to about half an hour
ago or a bit more um is an exercise from
a separate text book which is
exclusively in radians and it covers
more than just in extensions you've got
some identities in there you also have
some just solved some standard trig
equations you know so for example when
you see this okay for the beginning at
the beginning you're going to say okay i
still only know the answers to this in
degrees like that's at all i can recall
quickly right and so that takes some
time so i want to be able to get to the
point where i see this that signals
radians to me okay and so I think okay
I'm normally 30 in 150 I'm in first and
second quadrants what's the liability
raises pi 0 6 and then I think about the
other one which is the supplement of
this which is five players so you want
to get that point where you can recall
those fairly quickly because you're
comfortable with working it records and
take some time